[Music]
Hello friends and members of the Secrets
Unsealed and Some TV family. You're
watching I'd Like to Know, our Bible
question and answer program. Thank you
for sharing your day with us. And we've
got a lot of questions. We hope we've
got answers from the word of God. In
fact, we know we do. And we pray that
this program will be a blessing to you.
My name is Sierra Murray. I'm in the
company of Pastor David Salazar who
directs the work of our Latino channel
and pastor Steven Bore who is the
president and founder of this ministry.
Gentlemen, good to have you here. Always
a pleasure. Amen. We want to encourage
you to write us uh so that you can be a
part of this program. You can do so by
writing us at
TVsums as in
marytv.org. That is tvsumtv.org.
and we will get to your questions as
quickly as we possibly can. We have the
wonderful problem of having many many
questions to answer. Better to have too
many than too few. You agree with me? Uh
and we have a lot of questions, but we
want more. We're always looking for
more. We're always looking to answer
your particular questions. So, write us
if you will. We'll get to you with those
answers just as soon as we possibly can.
I'm going to open us up in prayer and
then we're going to read our first
question which comes to us from Henry.
We don't have a location. We always like
to get the location if it is at all
possible. But we will pray and then
we'll uh deal with this particular
question. Father God, we do praise you
and thank you for your word which is
indeed a lamp unto our feet and a light
into our path. We thank you, Father,
that the word is written for our
knowledge, for our edification, for our
growth as together we walk this road
that leads to glory. Thank you, Father,
that your word can be understood. It can
uh give us meet in due season. It can
answer our questions. It can direct us
as we uh try to draw closer to Jesus
Christ as your coming comes closer and
closer each and every day. And so bless
us now, Father, as we go to your word.
May you be the center and circumference
of all that we do and say, and may
Christ be glorified through our sitting
this day. We thank you in Jesus name.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Again coming to us
from
Henry. He speaks about Desmond Ford who
was dismissed from the ministry because
he preached heresy against the church. I
am noticing that the same exact message
is being promagated by h high ranking
theologians in our church today and yet
they are not being disciplined in any
way. Shouldn't we be throwing these the
theologians those theologians out of the
church as
well? Is it entire church? Is the entire
church in apostasy or is there just a
small are there just small pockets of
apostasy in the church?
Well, to a certain point, um, he's
right that we do have theologians in the
church that are teaching the same gospel
that Desmond Ford taught and they have
not been disciplined or they haven't
been dismissed. You know, we have to we
have to be honest
uh and we have to be equitable with
everybody. And uh we have theologians in
high places. We have administrators in
high places that have not been vi not
been dismissed
uh even though they have violated
decisions that have been made by the
world church. So let's just be honest.
Uh does that mean that the 7th day
advenist church is Babylon like some
people are saying? No. Uh the 7th
Adventist church has pockets of
apostasy. There's no doubt whatsoever
about that. But the church itself as a
whole is not an apostate church. Um but
you know our leaders should take
measures to be equitable in the way in
which they treat uh the the pastors and
the individuals in the church.
I think I first of all I agree with you.
Um I think there is this desire on the
part of many to sort of triage apostasy.
There's great apostasy, there's apostasy
that's not so great. You know, we tend
to kind of rank apostasy. Um if if
someone is preaching something that
deals with our basic fundamentals,
um or someone is taking money out of the
church, we tend to try to clamp down on
them pretty hard. particularly if it if
it's if they're taking money out of out
of the church. Other things we are a
little slower. Now granted Desmond Ford
had several conferences with the church.
They gave him great glacier view. There
were many many times when they brought
him in and spoke with him and of course
uh he was recalcitrin. Um the general
conference voted a number
of procedures
for conferences that were out of policy
with voting of the general conference.
To date to my understanding that has
never really been enacted, not certainly
with no teeth. Uh so he he is right as
you well said he he is right. There are
sometimes when we tend to hit the brake
a little quick or pause on our our
actions for whatever reason. But to be
fair, we must admit that there are there
are issues and those issues need to be
dealt with as people of God. They need
to be. But on the other hand, is the
church Babylon? Is the church in
apostasy? I I reject that notion. It is
still the object upon which God places
his supreme regard. He has never lost
control of the church. is not outside of
the church as the uh some theologians
have, you know, have postulated. He's
inside the church has always been is
now. But um do we have issues? Yeah. As
long as you got human beings running the
the show, yeah, it's it's
it's you have you will have problems.
But by the same token, u it's still
God's church and we can't give up on God
and God's leading. You know, if I just
might mention an example. Uh there's one
conference, which many of the ones who
are watching this program know which
conference I'm talking about. I'm not
going to mention it. That has a policy
that anyone who believes that women
should not be ordained as pastors cannot
speak in that conference.
Well, they're violating the vote of the
world church. Correct. Three times.
Why hasn't the general conference done
something with that
conference? Because it would rock the
boat
severely. And yet they'll throw
individuals off the boat. Yeah. So So
and and people see that. Yeah. And it
undermines confidence in the church.
Absolutely. It undermines confidence in
the leadership of the church when things
are not done in an equitable way no
matter what the consequences. Yes, we
have to do what is right and leave the
consequences to God. Uh but that isn't
always the case that it's done that way.
You know, I've been banned from
preaching in 27 different places. Yeah.
And everybody who watched this pro
watches this program knows that I am
100% with all of the message of the
Seventh Day Adventist Church, all 28
fundamental
beliefs. But they might not like my view
of women's ordination. They might not
like my view that God is going to have a
people victorious over sin at the end of
time. And therefore, uh, nothing is done
about it.
I I've complained to the general
conference a couple of times and and
nothing has been done
and it's wrong because an individual who
has a ministerial credential should have
the right to preach all over the world.
True. That's the purpose of the
ministerial credential. So the our
leadership has to be uh equitable. They
have to they have to do things in the
right way no matter the what the
consequences. they should not uh make a
distinction between one person and one
minister and another.
I think that you know the question as
Henry is mentioning is there apostasy
you know in the church. Sadly there is
and um fortunately there are individuals
who are promoting these messages that
contradict the fundamental beliefs of
Adventism and they are embraced
as popular as uh you know great
theologians. Maybe they speak very well.
they have you know many uh studies under
their their their name. Nevertheless,
uh God
is allowing individuals today to realize
what is truth and what is not. And and
it is really on the layman now that we
are to rely on to stand up for what
sometimes at churches are not doing,
what the leaders are not doing. And if
the ley is truly willing to follow the
Bible, they will help their leaders to
actually stand up to a higher standard.
And I think that's something that we are
to encourage people to do. not in a way
to go against the church or fight the
church, but to truly ask their
leadership to to to stand up and to be
more uh open-minded in regards to what
God is doing through ministers that are
preaching the truth messages that
embrace and have truly believe our
Adventist messages as we see it
throughout the Bible and the spirit
prophecy. So I I do invite individuals
to stand up and to um pray for the
leaders of the church. We are in a year
of of of elections for a president for
the general conference. I think it's
important that our ley prays that God
can set up leaders that have the
character of Moses who are going to
stand up for truth and not wave because
of pressure. Amen. Amen. And amen. I
remember back in 2007208
uh during that that big recession that
hit they were saying that there were
banks there that were too big to fail
you know so can't let them fail but they
did fail and and the country was rocked
by it but we survived and and maybe it's
going to take that kind of holy boldness
uh to deal with some of these issues in
the church when you when you have whole
conferences that are outside of policy
and and dare I say in some cases
divisions that are outside of policy. Um
it it would be a shaking an internal
shaking of astronomical proportion to to
try to get them back in line. But maybe
in these last days that is going to have
to happen if the church is going to be
what Christ wants it to be. Amen. We we
we say so many times that we are the
Leodysian church and that is true at
this given point in time but as you have
well said Christ is not coming back for
a Leodysian church right when he comes
back there's going to a a change will
have had taken place the church is going
to be spotless without wrinkle but it's
also going to be working for the Lord so
this amen this malaise that we are now
in will not define us till the end of
time um uh something is going to have to
happen and it may be dramatic, it may be
dramatic, but it is also necessary if
we're going to be the tool in the hand
of God that he wants us to be. Amen.
Yeah. And just kind of to end, uh I
don't believe the entire church is in
apostasy. I want to make that clear. Uh
I don't think the entire church in
apostasy. There is pockets of apostasy
in the church, but I I don't foresee the
church to be in in apostasy. And I
believe the church, this is the last
church that the Lord has established.
and this church will be become the
triumphant church that we are praying it
to be. Uh but um yeah so making sure
that that's clear because he has a
question Henry about it. Um this is
Henry part B. Yeah same he's another
question he has in no uncertain terms
LGT this is a quotation by the way from
the book on last generation theology of
Jerry Moscala at the seminary. Yeah. LGT
last generation theology upholds a
Pelagian view of the human condition of
the nature of sin and it is and it
denies the complete sufficiency of
Christ's sacrifice to save humanity and
effectively win the great controversy.
This view teaches that human beings must
do something even though it is claimed
to be by God's grace and by faith in
order to be saved and for the universe
finally to be redeemed from sin. In
fact, as the title of Herbert Douglas's
book, God at Risk suggests, humans are
saving God from failure. Christ suggests
on the cross, Christ sacrifice on the
cross is not sufficient to declare
victory over the forces of evil. Um, so
it's a statement. Um, here's a question
down here. Are these statements about
last generation theology correct? These
statements are made by critics of the
last generation theology movement.
These are not the only uh statements
I've heard against last generation
theology uh movement. A lot of them say
that having this says that you can work
your way into heaven and that you don't
need Christ. But really, if you study
it, it's just the opposite. Mhm. It it
it last generation theology says that
the work of Christ uh is complete and
that it is possible and that he can do
what he says he can do. So rather than
you working yourself in, it's simply
claiming and walking in the grace that
Christ has made for you, it not only
does it not take away from Christ, it it
it draws you to Christ in a salvific
way. You know, it's interesting that
this individual um uh you know, Jeremia
Moscala wrote this book and he basically
defines LGT uh and he actually quotes
that as a Pelagian view. Now the
pelagian uh view it's this theology that
is based on the of pelagos which is a
British monk back in the fourth fifth
fifth century who opposed the San
Augustian or Augustinian view of
original sin and what he believes is
basically that there's no original
sin and that um there is free will and
that grace is helpful but not essential.
This was this is what the pelagios
believed and this is the peligian view.
So obviously
uh I think that jury has not really
understood what lagination is. He's
putting the label connected to the view
of a monk that misunderstood and in some
regards was the opposite view of an
Augustine view of original sin. So I I
think that this jury is doing a
disservice to the church by presenting
this argument uh by by basically just
saying the generation is holding this
view of of of the pelagian understanding
of of of faith. And so, uh, I would
encourage even Jerry if he was to watch
this program, you know, to to actually,
uh, take that mindset off and truly
listen to what the messages are in
regards to the L generation because, uh,
you know, quite honestly, the idea that
we are uh, saved by our own works, that
somehow we believe that the the the
human nature is good in itself. That is
completely wrong. We, you know,
imaginary theology, at least the one
that I believe is is not that at all.
And so I think that this is a a wrong
declaration, a wrong understanding of
legendary technology and is truly trying
to pin us with or pin this term with a
concept that is against what it's truly
present in the Bible and is what we have
shared in this ministry. The bottom line
is that it's taken a long
process. But this whole process
began back in the 1949. Yeah. When a
note was changed in Bible readings for
the home. Then you have questions on
doctrine after that. There is a a
groundbreaking article that every
Adventist should read. It's written by
Fernando Canal who taught at the
seminary. I don't think that he would be
able to teach at the seminary seminary
today. Yeah, I doubt it very much. Uh
the title of it is a close look at the
Adventist mind and there's a subtitle.
It is always important to consider the
roots of our
thinking. And basically he says that the
7th Adventist church has been
Protestantized.
There's been a huge
shift in Adventist theology,
particularly Christologology,
from the sanctuary, yeah, to
righteousness by faith.
As the Protestant
denominations understand it,
a downgrading of just
sanctification and making justification
everything. Mhm.
When you make justification
everything, which means that it's our
assurance of salvation and that works
have nothing to do with your
salvation. Uh you basically
have Protestant theological views.
Only the Adventist church understands
through the sanctuary
um all of the process of salvation.
Right? Because salvation is not merely
the death of Jesus on the cross is not.
He had to live a perfect life, right? To
weave a robe. He had to die for sin.
Mhm. He had to resurrect from the dead
at the labor. He had a holy he has a
holy place ministry, a most holy place
ministry.
And then you have you have the scapegoat
ceremony which Protestantism rejects.
And so and so the Adventist sanctuary
view is radically different than
Protestant theology.
And this book basically this book by
Jerry Moscala is actually uh presenting
Adventist theology from the perspective
of Protestantism. Yeah. Apostate
Protestantism they might say.
Absolutely. Uh we do not believe that uh
the end time generation is going to live
without sin uh through their own
efforts. Exactly. The only way that it
can be done is through the power of the
Holy Spirit. Amen. Well, the Holy Spirit
is withdrawn from the earth. It's
withdrawn from the wicked. It's not
withdrawn from the righteous. Right.
Jesus is still going to be here as the
protector of his people. Mhm. By the
way, these individuals also they
downgrade the idea that after the close
of probation, there will be no
mediator. And for that reason, they have
to kind of cast aside what Ellen White
says that the saints will have to live
during the time of trouble without a
mediator. Well, if you're going to live
without a mediator, there's no mediation
for sin. Which means that this
generation has to overcome sin because
when probation closes, the sanctuary has
already been cleansed. Correct? Yeah.
So, if during the time of trouble,
that's the key. God's people are going
to sin. Is the sanctuary going to be
defiled again? No. Absolutely not. What
has happened in the seminary is that the
seminary has shifted our understanding
of righteousness by faith. Ellen has
Ellen White has a
statement where she says the
righteousness by which we are justified
is imputed. It means it's credited to
our account, right? The righteousness by
which we are sanctified
is imparted that is poured into us
is our um title, our title to heaven. In
other words, it's our right to get into
heaven. Amen. The second sanctification
is our fitness heaven. That's correct.
Exactly. Jesus is not going to take
anyone to heaven who is not credited
with the righteousness of Christ and who
has not been fitted for heaven by the
Holy Spirit. That's right. In other
words, justification and sanctification
are a package deal. When a person is
truly justified,
it will be exhibited by the fruit of
their lives. Amen. Amen. And and the
fruit of their lives is the result of
the work of the Holy Spirit. Yes. It's
not the result of the of the efforts of
the human being. Right? You know, God is
the one who wills and does amen his good
pleasure in our lives. And to say that
go that God is not going to have a
generation that will overcome sin. That
would reveal to the universe that in the
worst circumstances God will have a
people an entire generation of people
who are faithful to him is
simply I can't understand the reason why
they would criticize that other than
they want to teach that we're going to
continue sinning until Jesus comes on
the clouds. In other words, you can have
your cake and you can eat it too. Now
what's the difference? Christ revealed
that it is possible to
live a sinless life. So they say the
issue is finished. God doesn't need an
end time generation to show uh that it
is possible to live without sin. But
then the caveat is this that what what
they say is well you know Jesus had the
nature of Adam before the fall. That's
what the devil says. Yeah. He had the
nature of Adam before the fall. Of
course, he overcame. But God's people
can't overcome because they have a
sinful human nature. So, it all goes
back to what you believe about the
nature of Christ and the nature that we
have. If Jesus had a sinful nature and
we have a sinful nature, he overcame
sin, then it is possible for his people
also to overcome sin depending on the
father just like Jesus did. Yes. Amen.
Yes. And this is how p you know the the
Lord can invite us to follow his
examples to follow his example to follow
his walk to walk like he did to to have
the victory that he did because of the
power that he empowers us through the
grace of the Holy Spirit through the
grace of Christ that gives us the
ability to to obey. uh you know sadly
believing this new theology or this this
understanding of of apostate theology is
what causes individuals today to reject
our doctrines even our you know
fundamental beliefs in a way so uh I
think that's why the judgment uh is a is
a view that people reject today and and
unfortunately is coming from some
pastors even if you if you just lean on
on justification you have no motivation
to be an overcomer nothing to push you
to get better in your life you know you
know it is true If if you give your
heart to the Lord this moment and have a
heart attack and drop dead, you are
justified. You are saved. But as long as
you live, you got to keep getting
better. Amen. And that's and that's
that's what Christ does for you. Again,
our time slips away from us so fast. God
bless you. Keep studying. We'll see you
again soon. Bye-bye.
[Music]